Oh, was ganz Wichtiges vergessen!
*Glöckchen*
*Titelmelodie*
Freunde der Sonne, herzlich
willkommen zu "Advent-Chemie Teil 2",
heute: mit Justus!
Justus ist
ein Hawaiianischer Drachenbaum,
nur heute wird er zum Weihnachtsbaum!
Ihr kennt das ja bestimmt, auf
Pinterest oder auch auf YouTube
gibt es ganz viel DIY-Weihnachtsdeko.
Die sieht zwar schön aus, aber ihr
habt einfach keinen Bock zu basteln!
Deswegen
machen wir es heute andersrum:
Ich zeig euch
heute DIY-Weihnachtsdeko,
die zwar nicht so schön aussieht,
aber dafür richtig Bock macht!
Weil: Chemie!
Also erst mal
braucht Justus ein paar Lichter.
Schön!
Jetzt muss Justus
natürlich auch geschmückt werden.
Chemiker-Style!
Könnt ihr auch
ganz einfach zu Hause nachmachen:
Man nimmt Kalium-Aluminium-Sulfat,
destilliertes Wasser,
erhitzt das Ganze, bis es sich löst,
lässt es abkühlen,
nimmt Filzanhänger
und Stäbchen,
hängt die in ein Glas,
gießt die abgekühlte Lösung rein,
macht das noch ein paar Mal,
schläft 'ne Nacht drüber.
Und am nächsten Tag hat man
wunderschöne Anhänger mit Kristallen,
die ein bisschen aussehen wie Zucker,
die man aber nicht essen sollte!
Hawaiianische Drachenbäume...
lassen sich nicht so gut schmücken.
Ich brauch Tesa!
*Musik "Stille Nacht"*
So, das sieht jetzt
schon sehr...
... schön aus!
Aber ich glaube, es fehlt
noch ein bisschen Winterflair.
Was ist schon Weihnachten
ohne Schnee?
Doch Justus, der hawaiianische
Drachenbaum mag Schnee nicht so sehr.
Zum Glück bin ich Chemikerin
und kann Kunstschnee herstellen!
Wir füllen ein bisschen Wasser hinzu.
# Snow is glistening
# A beautiful sight
# We're happy tonight
# Walking in a winter wonderland
# Gone away...
Keksfrage an euch:
Was war das für ein Magic Pulver,
mit dem ich den Schnee gemacht habe?
Und: Wie funktioniert es genau?
Kleiner Tipp: Es funktioniert ganz
ähnlich wie dieser Beauty Blender.
So, eigentlich wollte ich Justus
noch ein paar künstliche Eisberge
da unten hinsetzen, doch leider
ist mir das hier passiert.
Keksfrage an euch:
Was ist hier drin?
Tipp 1: Es entstand im letzten
Weihnachtsvideo, im Teil 1.
Und Tipp Nr.2: Es ist schön warm.
Ich stell das jetzt
einfach mal hier in den Schnee.
Ich habe euch ja gesagt:
Das wird heute nicht so schön.
*Musik*
Also Leute, jede korrekte chemische
Erklärung in den Kommentaren
kriegt von mir persönlich
ein Keks-Emoji.
Wenn ihr nach Erklärungen
sucht, aber keine habt,
dann schaut
doch mal in die Kommentare.
Wir haben hier
eine sehr schlaue Community!
*Ukulelenklang*
Bleibt sicher Freunde,
wir sehen uns in der Endcard.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
# You better watch out,
you better not cry
# You better not pout,
I'm telling you why
# @maithink is on Instagramm
Folgt mir auf Instagram.